[Musique]
estimez-vous bien manger est ce que tu
sais pas de combien faire l'épicerie
n'ont vraiment pas serré mais nous notre
famille on est quatre en forme ça coûte
cher des épiceries mais
6 par année j'en ai vraiment aucune sauf
le cas aujourd'hui
des élèves du 2e secondaire de l'école
sophie barat du quartier ahuntsic à
montréal se vendent à l'épicerie le
professeur de mathématiques guillaume
caisse ou est l'instigateur d'un projet
scolaire c'est conjointement avec les
professeurs de français et d'éducation
physique
le voile est trés s'inscrit dans un
projet qui s'appelle mon avenir il doit
donc se trouver un emploi avoir un
salaire et où il effectivement
l'épicerie fait partie du projet parce
que c'est un peu une portion importante
d'un budget quand on sera plus vieux en
fait
[Musique]
ce projet tente de faire des élèves des
consommateurs avertis en les aidant à
décrypter les bons produits pour faire
les choix adéquat
ils ont d'établir les au menu deux sites
pour un déjeuner en équipe et souhaite
une conférence qu'ils ont eu de la part
d'une nutritionniste viandes volailles
poissons et lui toufik silva qui
concerne le tofu dans la classe
ah ouais bon ça c'est bravo qu'avec ce
projet là bas ça me permet de voir qu
effectivement des mathématiques que ce
soit au niveau du calcul de la masse des
volumes évidemment des coûts baissent à
une utilité donc en seconde alors que
s'ils voient les proportions et alors ça
permet d'appliquer concrètement ce
qu'ils ont vu en classe à l'épicerie les
élèves ont tenté d'appliquer les
conseils de la conférencière en
nutrition avant de se rendre à
l'épicerie ou trois agressions fait que
ça des libyens on les a déjà qu'on mari
mais en plus cette sorte que ces vidéos
à l'endroit serait temps d'en apprendre
franchement qui tout comme une g de
sucre
c'est ici que 0 le ce matin qu'est ce
que tu as appris que tu ne savais pas
que je suis aussi appris que par exemple
que les ingrédients et l'oncle c'est
mauvais
des baraques est choisi et des bijoux a
affecté de conservation des données
personnelles
le rôle de la professeur de français mme
l'établi la vigueur est tout aussi
capital mon rôle c'est de faire en sorte
qu'ils lisent bien les étiquettes a les
ingrédients la valeur nutritive est ce
que les promesses qu'on voit sur les
emballages sont au rendez vous c'est de
travailler beaucoup l'analyse
comparative parce que quand on fait
notre épicerie tout est à propos de ça
et comment tu veux savoir ce pour les
intolérants sur la comète
quand on a des intolérances ou d énergie
on est obligé d'analyser chaque produit
pour voir ça nous convient ou non
qu'est-ce que calculée
on calcule les proportions pour le yoga
pour savoir combien on doit incomber
s'avancer pour m
un matin
vous prenez en compte mais en fait c'est
très simple si le prix selon le nombre
de grandes qu on a décidé qu'on va
manger pour une tension est donc on va
fonctions parce que le c200 fin une
grande chance pour 4 89
on a des bons échos de la part des
parents qui sont à ses contacts
car laurent femme mettant les
accompagner l'épicerie et des foins un
esprit critique face à leurs choix
alimentaires
champignon mortel et s'est déroulé
exactement comme nous les clubs
c'est donc une fois qu'ils ont terminé
leur épicerie qu'ils ont chiffré tout ça
évidemment ils retournent en classe et
là ils doivent calculer exactement
combien chaque ingrédient à chaque item
la route et sont surpris de voir la
partie importante que l'épicerie à
présent dans une chaîne e
moi je me suis trouvé un appartement
alors j'ai 17 ans et je savais rien de
la vie je savais pas comment faire une
épicerie je savais même pas ce qu'est ce
que c'était de manger équilibré et puis
l'aubade d'offrir à ses élèves le la
chance d'avoir un regard concret sur ce
que sait faire l'épicerie de voir que
bon ça ça coûte cher d'avoir peut-être
un petit peu plus de respect pour le
travail des parents mais moi je me dis
que pour l'instant j'en profite parce
que c'est moi qui paye
mais j'y pense papilles jour ou l'autre
un avenir pis
voilà je profite encore y penser pour
las
[Musique]